Dónde está Jenny pregon Hasta ahora se
creía que el líder Mercenario de Wagner
se encontraba en velarus que lo acogió
como parte de un acuerdo para poner fin
a su rebelión Armada contra Moscú el 24
de junio pero el jueves el presidente
Alexander lucashenko reveló que prigo
jin se encuentra en realidad en Rusia
está en San Petersburgo dónde está esta
mañana puede que viaje a Moscú o que
esté en otro lugar pero no está en el
territorio de
velarúsculo también afirmó que pregojin
es un hombre libre y que Rusia no
acabará con él velarus me dio en un
acuerdo con el kremlin de que pregojin
puso fin a su insurrección contra Moscú
a cambio de garantías de seguridad para
él y sus soldados pero ahora esas
garantías parecen inciertas la semana
pasada se retiraron los cargos penales
contrarigoyen pero los medios de
comunicación favorables al kremlin han
empezado a atacarle después de meses de
elogiar su accionar en Ucrania la
televisión Estatal rusa informó el
miércoles que se sigue investigando a
fondo la insurrección y tachó a pregojin
de traidor los medios también han
publicado imágenes de la mansión de
pregojin en San Petersburgo
supuestamente llena de armas lingotes de
oro y pelucas los servicios de seguridad
rusos allanaron La Mansión sin embargo
el kremlin Afirma no estar siguiendo la
pista de pregon
no estamos vigilando sus movimientos no
tenemos ni la capacidad ni el deseo de
hacerlo
el pasado fin de semana todos los
rótulos del grupo Wagner fueron
retirados de su antigua sede en San
Petersburgo al tiempo que el kremlin
iniciaba la absorción del imperio
empresarial de pregon El Líder
Mercenario de 62 años lleva casi dos
semanas sin aparecer en público